when I was in Fifth Harmony we didn't
win the show we like came in third place
and I I know a lot of people from these
competition shows have had that
experience Camila Cabello sharing wise
words to Future The Voice contestants
it's really just you learn so much when
you're here and you just have the
opportunity to like you know be in LA
and like work on your craft then just
like be like a sponge and at the same
time you have new eyeballs on you and
who knows it's like that it's such an
unpredictable Journey too it's like the
goal just like anything shouldn't be
just on winning because just you being
here and growing it's like you never
know what doors that's going to open up
and with new opportunities comes new
faces
Chance the Rapper and Niall Horan will
join the coaches for season 23. I know
chance but I know Nile better
um and I just think they're both going
to be so fun and they both have so much
personality and
are just so kind of like grounded and
have such great sense of humor so I
think it'll be fun I think it would be
really fun to see their chemistry with
Blake too and Kelly when it comes to
longtime coach Blake Shelton ending his
run on the competition series Camila
doesn't seem too upset about it yes I
think I'm just kidding
the singer also reveals her perfect
parting gift for Blake some kind of
amazing alcohol
because he loves alcohol in the meantime
Season 22 is gearing up for its first
live shows and Camila came with the
fashion well okay so I'm into like the
dark Academia Vibe
um so I go on Pinterest and I have a
Pinterest board of like outfits that
inspire me like things that I would wear
and the dark Academia thing has just
been on my mind maybe it's because it's
fall I also like my best self I like
read a lot and listen to a lot of poetry
and
it just reminds me to I don't know to be
a learner to be like studying as for how
she's hoping fans will make their votes
count this season Camilla's got an idea
I mean I will streak across the stage
naked to get America to vote
um but I think that you know one thing I
was just talking about I think this show
is like so unpredictable like
somebody that you could with such an
underdog in the auditions that you like
barely remember
suddenly just like blossoms into this
butterfly and you're like wow maybe you
could win the show oh maybe you could
win this so things change so much that
it's just exciting to see the growth of
people and see them kind of develop and
and to you know have a little bit more
like star power as opposed to just you
know being good singers like everybody
works on or the opposite
um everybody like works on their thing
and I think it's like totally
unpredictable what is gonna happen like
I don't know hopefully my team wins for
sure
foreign